our society assumes that emotional
education might be either unnecessary
or in its essence unteachable lying
beyond reason and best abandoned to
individual instinct we are left to find
our own path around our unfeasibly
complicated Minds a move about as wise
as leaving each generation to rediscover
the laws of physics by themselves but
the school of life believes that the
journey to finding fulfillment begins
with self-knowledge with emotional
intelligence the emotionally intelligent
person is able to introspect and
communicate to read the moods of others
to relate with patience charity and
imagination to those around them the
emotionally intelligent person knows how
to hope and be grateful while remaining
steadfast before the essentially tragic
structure of existence the emotionally
intelligent person is committed to
fathoming their inadequacies their kin
wisely be no solutions that remove
problems altogether
what we can aim for at best is
consolation to believe in consolation
means giving up on cures it means
accepting that life is a hospice rather
than a hospital but one we'd like to
render as comfortable as interesting and
as kind as possible the school of life
dares to believe that we might learn in
good time and systematically what we
might otherwise acquire only through
many decades of stumbling the school of
life teaches us how we can live a little
better through a deeper understanding of
the self others our relationships our
work and our culture if as a society we
have collectively left to chance
some of what it's most important to know
if we have denied ourselves the
opportunity to systematically transmit
wisdom then the school of life is a
modest attempt to try to spare us a bit
of time
you